the function H is defined for all real
numbers and they graph y is equal to H
of X right over here that's what they're
showing us and they ask us what is a
reasonable estimate for the limit as X
approaches negative 7 of H of X and they
give us some choices for those
reasonable estimates including the
possibility that the limit does not
exist so I encourage you to pause the
video and see if you can work through
this yourself
alright now let's think about what's
going on so something is interesting it
x equals negative 7 and x equals
negative 7 we have the function it is
defined but it is not continuous with
the rest of the function H of negative 7
H of negative 7 is looks like a little
bit it looks like it's like negative
four point something so it's
approximately negative four point I
don't know it's like negative four point
one something something something so
that's what H of negative seven is and
sometimes there's this temptation say oh
whatever the function equals that that
must be what the limit is but this is
actually a really good example for
showing the difference that many times
the limit exists and is approaching or
it is a value different than what the
value that the function takes on at that
point and so let's think about the limit
as X approaches negative seven from
smaller values of X so as X gets closer
and closer to negative seven it looks
like the value of our function is
approaching where we have this gap so it
looks like our function is getting
closer the value of our function is
approaching this value right over here
similarly if we were to approach from
the left so for approach for more
negative values it looks like the value
of our function is approaching that same
thing and since it looks like it's
approaching the same value whether we're
coming from more negative values or less
negative values we know or we can we can
assume or we have a good sense that this
limit exists we seem to be approaching
the same value now it's a valued
then the actual value of the function
there the value of the function there is
that negative 4.1 or something like that
now this looks like the function itself
is approaching this looks like I don't
know one point one point two one point
three something like that so I look at
our choices what's a reasonable estimate
for this limit well it's definitely not
negative seven the function is
definitely not approaching y equals
negative seven this is kind of a
distractor choice because this is what X
is approaching X is approaching negative
seven but we want to know what is the
function approaching what is the value
of H approaching as X approaches
negative seven so let's rule that one
out
negative four point one so negative four
point one is an interesting choice
because that's a good approximation for
what the actual value of the function is
there the function is defined there
although it kind of jumps and is defined
right over here and it's it's
discontinuous so this is more of what H
this could be a reasonable estimate for
H of negative seven what the function
actually is defined to be at x equals
negative seven but as we approach x
equals as we approach negative seven it
is not approaching the value of the
function does not seem to be approaching
negative four point one so I'm going to
rule that one out now one point three
that is what that is a pretty reasonable
estimate for what the function seems to
be approaching as X gets closer and
closer to negative seven you know six
point nine six point nine nine or
negative six point nine negative six
point nine nine negative six point nine
nine nine nine from the right or from
the left negative seven point one
negative seven point zero one negative
seven point zero zero one so on and so
forth it looks like the value of that
function is approaching approximately
one point three so I like that choice
right over there
one point eight that's just another
choice but this looking approximating
where this is it definitely looks closer
to one than it does to two so I'd rule
that one out
and I would say that this limit does
exist because it looks like we're
approaching the same value whether we're
coming from below or from above
so to speak